despite appearing in over 200 episodes
across 12 seasons of the big bang theory
there's a lot we don't know about penny
what's her maiden name why haven't we
ever seen her sister stick around to
learn the untold truth about penny
a common misconception about penny is
that her maiden name was never revealed
before she married leonard and took his
last name hofstadter however penny's
last name is actually revealed in the
season 2 episode the work song nano
cluster when penny gets a package
delivered as she's attempting to start
her own company on the packing label her
full name penny teller is visible you
definitely have to squint a little bit
but upon a close-up inspection of the
package it looks like it's addressed to
a teller what's most interesting about
this little tidbit of information is
that in 2019 at wondercon's panel for
the big bang theory when executive
producer steve molero was asked about
penny's last name he responded we got
nervous and superstitious about giving
her one perhaps he forgot about that
blink and you'll miss it detail from
season 2.
penny is a character who likes to talk
and her family is one of her favorite
subjects penny tells plenty of stories
about her colorful childhood and one
character who comes up frequently is her
sister lisa audiences know that lisa is
married has a son and that she
discovered penny's ex-boyfriend's blog
that detailed his love life with her my
friends at work found it my sister found
it judging by my email a number of
prisoners at the michigan state
penitentiary found it
despite the repeated references
audiences have never actually seen lisa
she didn't even make it to penny and
leonard's wedding which feels
exceptionally odd judging from the
number of times penny mentions lisa in
the series they seem close
and yet somehow the audience meets
penny's brother randall a meth dealer
who spends the majority of the show in
prison instead of her sister
the literal geniuses of the big bang
theory can be difficult for most
audience members to relate to so penny
serves as someone that viewers can
connect with however penny wasn't always
meant to be a part of the ensemble in
the original unaired pilot penny's role
on the show is filled by katie a
completely different character played by
amanda walsh according to comic book
katie was described as being quote a
street hardening tough-as-nails woman
with a vulnerable interior however all
the networks passed on this penniless
version of the show including its
eventual home cbs in a dvd special
feature actress kaylee cuoco revealed
that when she originally auditioned for
the big bang theory she didn't get the
part as katie was more of a brooding
character but once the show cut katie
and replaced her with penny cuoco was a
lock for the gig
kaylee cuoco told variety that she was
brought into a meeting and told that she
would be saying goodbye to penny sooner
than expected cuoco recalled that it was
the summer of 2018 and the cast had just
started shooting for season 12. she and
co-star johnny galecki assumed the
meeting was about the next season and
she remembers the two actors being
excited to continue with their
characters of course the conversation
went in a different direction jim
parsons who played sheldon said he was
ready to move on from the show then
creator chuck laurie announced if they
weren't all in it made sense to end the
series season 12 would be the final
season leaving cuoco in what she
described as a state of shock she noted
that there were many tears especially in
the final episode from the entire cast
and crew she also shared that her father
attended every taping that season you
know i just want the elevator to get
fixed
please
what a finale what a way to go out
the big bang theory had a total of 279
episodes across its 12-season run and
the entire main cast appeared in every
single one except for penny that is
that's because kaylee cuoco broke her
leg and had to miss some tapings
according to entertainment weekly cuoco
was horseback riding and was thrown off
her horse she initially laughed the
moment off but the horse was still
spooked by the incident and attempted to
jump over the actress landing on her leg
by accident cuoco was immediately taken
to the hospital where the doctors were
so concerned about infection that they
even brought up the option of amputation
luckily they ended up putting two metal
bars into her leg instead resulting in a
two-week hospital stay that mandated
penny be written out of two big bang
theory episodes once cuoco returned to
set the writers gave penny a bartending
job so that she could be shot from the
waist up hiding her injured leg behind
the counter check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite characters
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you